like he'll try and find any and fight
for example he defends pedophiles he's
like pedophile they have no rights the
heat always goes on about like how
pedophiles have no rights and they're
disrespected and I I'm gonna say this
and I can't believe I'm gonna say this
oh all right and you might have to edit
this out just you know I mean but what
the most infuriating TV show ever made
was catching a predator mm-hmm it's a
great show
that's a great point especially when a
kid is 19 or 20 and the girls supposed
to be 16 a four-year difference right
first of all somebody made the age 18 it
doesn't say it in the Bible does it in
the Bible say that you know mean a 20
year old and a 17 year old can't fog the
us go you know what's a but a human
being some human being
Lamia lawmaker made it up because I
almost feel like a 16 year old in the
United States is far less emotionally
and mentally developed than the 16 year
old in other countries I really really
do believe that I think that they are
stunted here um just you know we we
reared them differently here because I
mean you're right like in the
Philippines nobody bats an eyelash when
when a 20-something year old dates a 15
year old
I mean sometimes that 15 year old can
really hold her own when I was 12 I had
an 18 year old boyfriend and I blew him
I didn't lose my virginity to him but I
blew him regularly
do you know what and he used a finger
blast man I didn't even have my period
yet you just took his [ __ ] and you
know it and he was his indoor [ __ ] a
little [ __ ] and he was a weld he's
still well-known businessmen like he is
or he's a piece of guy this is I've
never heard this before you know I
[ __ ] met him he sure had
up from the airport port that [ __ ] I
remember him now
Wow we use this van we used to spend the
guy that finger-blasted my girlfriend
what you just learned
Wow my island is so small everybody kind
of knows everybody if she said there's
like eight people like there's eight
people on the island a hundred million
people did you it like feel anything
when you were 12 getting yeah it was
super horny I I think I was horny even
before I knew what horny was but did you
like you didn't have an orgasm I did
yeah I had my very first orgasm at 12
and I couldn't understand my emotion the
only thing I hated about the experience
was that I felt extremely depressed
afterwards like a lot of guilt after the
orgasm likely kind of like post-coital
blues when did you lose your virginity
Master I guess kind of young 15 after a
Britney Spears concert we decided to
just go for it
we've been together for one month and I
had a crush on him for like a year so
it's like if this I gotta just go for
this did he you have hair down there
[Laughter]
question see most girls are fully haired
he's still shocked from the fact that
you learn that he different you know go
back to why you hate catching a predator
oh yeah it's entrapment or do you think
it there's some entrapment there and
it's also like um okay if you're a 40
year old man obviously a 40 year old man
with a wife and kids and you're trying
to get a six year old girl that's
[ __ ] weird does that mean you deserve
to be put on blast on a TV show I don't
know especially it's also you know it
it's not a court of law
the show it's not right so basically
what they're doing is they're ruining a
somebody's life forever it's TV
you know so basically they have kids
they have you know a wife maybe he has a
screw loose and he made a bad decision
I mean it's [ __ ] up yes okay and it's
illegal all right I get it
but I don't think that a 19 or 20 or old
boy yet I mean who's trying to get [ __ ]
a 17 overall should be you know I mean I
don't I don't think I don't think the
only reason he's saying this is because
a couple days ago he doesn't know this
but I found out he signed up for a new
site called Club 17 it's probably a porn
site mister you don't sign up for porn
sites where he pays for and he's HD yeah
because he needs HD only what is closed
well the first boo solders for youngers
and then now the new one is Club 17 and
he doesn't know I know but oh it's
another reveal just now yeah I belong to
different porn sites what's your budget
I spend like I don't know one of them is
like $100 a year or whatever
there are like $100 a year to be your
package I don't like grainy porn porn
hub is a yeah grainy grainy you know man
like I needed to be clear I like newer
you know I mean just newer girls you
know and um yeah I mean I watched
pornography and I've certainly she's you
know I was into a couple months ago
though the one the old men men in the
little girls like eight year old men and
a teen or girls is that oh I found out
and I had to confront him on his
audacity I know it could be wrong and I
you know what I stopped watching that
because he's on Club 17 no no it's Club
so don't just say something about Club
17 okay
he's plug for that right [ __ ] up all
right Club 17 there are other umbrellas
underneath right yeah so it's like her
networks like know what the [ __ ] up all
right you don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about okay so what I'm saying is
is that have you heard of Tom Nieto you
haven't Tom Nieto is a skateboarding you
know mean company but they have
different skateboarding companies within
that they have girl not I think girl or
if it's zero
you know Toy Machine they're all under
Tom you yet OHS you know umbrella right
and like they're different
no dude even skate teams in you know
ones punk rock once more Ivy League
whatever you know so it's like Club 17
has an umbrella so there's a specific I
don't watch Club 17 there's something
else that that's all you know I don't I
just feel really like swatting I'm
defensively because no that's not it
it's because now you tied in right
catching a predator because with club
and seventh leg way and I was defending
you know I mean the pedophile is on
you're catching now I feel like I'm
trying to be a pedophile and I'm not but
to make you feel better
Dave doesn't think pedophiles are all
that bad he are you fan it's just that
they're treated unfairly you know they
have to register in neighborhoods where
like certain people don't also like
think of they're fighting this like
desire that they don't want to have and
I mean he'll say so he sees it as a
mental illness that you just you're
basically like hardwired to be a certain
I think so yeah I mean I can't say I can
but yeah no I think I mean it's like
saying it's like saying I I see to some
people see it as a mental illness right
your how you don't know that person's
past traumas you don't know what led up
to his like current behavior being like
a pedophile and he has this just strong
urge to commit what we consider a crime
and he doesn't know where it comes from
he just feels this urge right it's like
this hunger
[Music]